I have to say congrats you were just
inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame
[Applause]
I brought this for the show because this
is my rock and roll and I just want to
share this with you until you get your
own and you will oh wow
I think you have well it's funny
I'll be talking to my producer this
morning and I was like
we throw around the word icon a lot like
I feel like everybody's an icon now like
you know everybody's like oh she's an
icon I'm like no you have to earn that
and you actually earned that and it's
like you that's why I loved your
response I loved your response because
you're relaxed well wait what rock and
roll like I'm country music but you are
rock and roll the fact that you're a
Pioneer for women you've opened the
doors for so many of us to be able to be
vulnerable as songwriters but I don't
know does it make does it weird you out
to be labeled an icon does it well I
always think of myself more than I saw
well I wish actually but you know I I
used to think when I was young if I made
it like I hoped out would how people
would remember me when I was older now
I'm older and it's really nice to look
back and think that you know I might
have done something that's helped
Inspire oh my God so many of some other
people and when I got into the Rock and
Roll uh hall of fame or when they talked
about that I didn't realize that it was
it was more than just that to me I'd
always thought about the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame being for people to spend
their life in rock music like country
music and we don't see Led Zeppelin In
the Country Music Hall of Fame yeah you
know so I when they first said that I
thought well you know I don't know that
I belong there and I didn't want to take
votes from other people that had spent
their life and that's kind of how far
is that but still I honestly thought
that but then later I saw that it was
for people also that have you know
influenced other people and and I did
say I would accept it gracefully and
humbly and I did and I was very honored
but but you did so something even cooler
you actually wrote like a rock and roll
song I did yeah song for the show about
my whole experience about that is called
I've been it's called rocking it because
I've been rocking it I grew up loving
Elvis and and wild man Jerry Lee took
very little Richard Richard Dale had a
cast a spell on me and uh Carl Perkins
and them Blue Suede Shoes had no place
on the farm that's better than them
Brogan's I was wearing around the barn
so I've been rocking rock and rocking
since the day I was born I'll be rocking
till the day I'm gone cause I got rock
and roll down in my country so and I'll
be rocking it till the cows come home
[Applause]
that's so perfect
I'll go ahead and I'll talk about the
whole thing how you know how they you
know they put me in the Hall of Fame so
I guess it ain't no Shameless you know
but since I heard the big news I ain't
never been the same because they've done
gone and put me in the rock and roll oh
baby it's a dangerous thing but I was
honored and I'm proud so and it's so
cool though how you do you you're so
respectful of other artists and all
their hard work but at the same time
you're like because you're doing an
album now like a rock album Rock album
[Applause]
I'm doing uh classic songs I'm using a
lot of the classic artists too to sing
on some of the songs with me so wow so
I'm looking forward to that so that's
going to come out next year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]